coming up Marc Jacob and Steven case
recall the role that Philadelphia
socialite Peggy Shippen Benedict
Arnold's second wife played in the
conspiracy to harm George Washington's
forces this program is just under an
hour
[Applause]
thank you for coming I'm Marc Jacob
Stephen cases to my left and we started
studying a couple years ago Stephen many
years ago discovered Peggy story just an
underappreciated story in American
history
in fact she was probably the most
dangerous teenage girl in American
history and you know half the age of her
husband or finical was much more famous
and it's just it's a story that nobody
really knew in fact it just kind of it
was poorly understood at the time even
and by the time anyone understood what
the story was nobody seemed to care
anymore if Peggy was mrs. Benedict
Arnold and she liked it that way she
didn't want to be anything else she
would much rather be the victimized wife
of a traitor than be considered what the
real truth is which is a co-conspirator
to try to bring down the American
Revolution and who had fooled the
founding fathers and got off scot-free
which is exactly what you did all right
about more than a century after her
death British papers in the general
Clinton's archives are finally studied
by American scholars and they figure out
well there was always really important
circumstantial evidence to indicate that
Peggy Shippen was certainly a part of
the plot and there's no smoking gun but
there you know as tons of circumstantial
evidence not that I think any reasonable
person would agree that she knew all
about it and was part of the pot and but
by that time you know she had really
kind of gotten the past from history and
Stephen and I think wanted to bring this
story to another generation and focus
the story on Peggy she's been kind of
just a supporting character and a lot of
biographies of Benedict Arnold and we
just wanted to Center it on her and
write it in a different way you want to
start talking about it a little bit
imagine you were in damascus syria
not long ago the violence erupted in
distant cities Aleppo at home and it
took a while to get to Damascus and you
are a prominent accountant professional
of some kind what do you do about this
war that suddenly in the capital city
where you have achieved prosperity and
prominence do you support the insurgents
do you support the government or do you
just try to say how do I get through
this and come out in one piece with my
life and my family intact well that's
what the story of Peggy Shippen and her
family is and it's all about
Philadelphia from 1774 to shortly before
1780 Peggy's grandfather was a
co-founder of what is now Princeton
University Father extremely a prominent
lawyer in the community very wealthy the
family were slave owners still reporting
in the 1790 census they had three slaves
they have several children and Mark and
I think that the father decided to play
the war by being as neutral as he could
get away with leaving no clear message
to the children about which side they
were on
so what happens in 1774 in September the
First Continental Congress meets in
Philadelphia George Washington of
Virginia shows up the practically the
first night he was there he was invited
to dinner at the shipping home Peggy got
met him then for the first time and knew
him very well until she had a falling
out and then we get the Declaration of
Independence when she's 16 which is
literally signed about a block and a
half around the corner from the family's
fancy home
and then we get to September 1777 and
the British and the person chosen to be
the military governor of the
Philadelphia area is Benedict Arnold now
by that time he's had a grievous leg
wound that's made him unable to ride a
horse and have to ride in the coach and
he's won he's proved himself to be the
most audacious and able battlefield
commander on the Continental Army side
recognized that way by George Washington
so he's 38 and Peggy is 18 when they
when they marry they have a courtship of
about a year and this happens let me
back up just a little bit
Peggy became kind of this society
debutante at the age of 16 or 17 shortly
after the Declaration of Independence
was was signed and the war really
started in earnest they ended up the
British ended up taking Philadelphia and
holding it for about nine months and
during that time
Peggy became very friendly with some of
the British officers say I think be a
lot more fun than the the Patriot
officers say there's especially a guy
named John Andre who was just as
brilliant captain who wrote poetry
played the flute acted in plays and
wrote plays and spent a lot of time at
Peggy's house and became a great friend
of hers and but the British ultimately
had to leave Philadelphia and go back to
New York and then Arnold comes in who's
really nothing like Andre Andres kind of
handsome and vibrant and Arnold by that
time is 38 years old and grievously
wounded and limping around now mark when
the British left did they do anything
special they I don't know sure most even
you know they there was something called
this is another thing you know when
Stephen I started studying this in
earnest we with the help of a really a
brilliant team of academic researchers
who
with Stephen kind of recruited and they
found great documents for us because we
couldn't have done it alone so there was
this event called the mushy Anza that
neither that I certainly had never heard
of and I just wonder why they didn't
teach it is a big blow up party in
Philadelphia in the middle of this we
this occupation of by the British
meanwhile this is it happens in the
spring just when the terrible winter of
Valley Forge is happening so the
Continental Army is in Valley Forge and
the horses are dying and people are
dying and they're barely surviving the
British are having a great time in
Philadelphia and begi is too is enou so
it's the worst time in many people's
life but it's maybe the best in the
hearse and they had this party called
the mushy ons which cost an incredible
amount of money to where they had paid
12,000 pounds worth of dresses were sold
which I think converts was it convert to
push in the mill any hundreds of them
yeah there are conversions to modern
currency that we use in the book they're
really rough but I mean just some
ungodly amount of money they get these
bands floating on barges and go up the
Delaware River they take over the
Wharton mansion because Wharton was a
patriot and had to flee but even the
working mansion wasn't big enough for
this party they built a separate dining
hall just for the event and so I mean
they're spending millions they know
incredible amounts of money John Andre
this dashing officer is pretty much in
charge of designing everything and we've
designed what colors the the rooms would
be and things like that
so it it was just absurd little oasis in
the middle of this terrible war so the
British leave leaving Peggy there and
you know disappointed and Benedict
Arnold comes he immediately she's you
know known as the most beautiful woman
in Philadelphia or she's later described
as the most beautiful woman in North
America and then later when she goes
into exile in London spoiler alert there
she
and too late but she ends up she's
called the most beautiful woman in
England so she's just very highly
regarded and she doesn't miss a beat as
far as going to parties with Benedict
Arnold making sure Benedict Arnold
spends a lot of money on parties and you
know lavish stuff so Arnold is kind of
besieged you wanna get into a little bit
of this why Arnold would have turned
traitor well he was a feisty guy who
didn't fit well into groups and even
before the war started he was in duels
with people in the Caribbean he'd been
in the shipping business and he was
serving after the British left as the
military commander of Philadelphia and
my candidate for the bad guy in this
story is the civilian head of government
in Pennsylvania man named Joseph Reed
was exactly the same age and my judgment
not terribly well supported by the
record but it's a aroma that the blood I
many things I've read give me is the one
Arnold a Connecticut man surfaced in
Pennsylvania and married into the
richest most prominent family in town or
one of them he saw Arnold as a rival for
post-war political power and he started
the precedent for Watergate first there
was a smear of Arnold on eight charges
of wrongdoing of various kinds and this
since created a congressional committee
hearing under a congressman from
Maryland named paka and nothing ever
changes in this country the
congressional committee punted on the
outcome didn't want to criticize the
finest field commander and the
revolution so far the hero of
Ticonderoga the hero of Saratoga etc so
they bucked it to George Washington with
a suggestion of a court-martial and
Washington had no choice but to start
court-martial proceedings and Arnold was
really mad about it and this all broke
just about the time that he married
right the 19 year old
young lady who had had the relationship
not ten months earlier with the handsome
25 year old British officer John Andre
so what mark within how many what time
period although after the wedding does
the documentation show that the
communication with the British began on
the spy scandal or in Houla did they
communicate with within a month
Arnold's get some kind of guy who really
likes the British but somehow it's been
able to maintain a residence in
Philadelphia and they asked him to find
his way to New York City and he does and
he asked for John Andre now
coincidentally John Andre isn't just a
captain anymore by this time John Andre
being such a being such a brilliant and
influential and well liked guy is acting
adjutant general of the entire Army in
effect with the chief of staff to
general Clinton and he also slowly takes
over all spy duties so he becomes a spy
master of the British forces in North
America so here you have one one of
Peggy's best friends is suddenly the
chief spy of the British Army and so a
month right and month after their
marriage this letter goes and says hey
we want to join the British we will do
whatever we can to help now we don't
know and we in the book we don't guess
you know we don't speculate much at all
we say all right we don't know how this
came about it could have been this this
or this in this case they could have
made a joint decision she could have
influenced she could have begged him to
do it or he could have been his decision
we don't know
mark is a careful scholarly journalist I
think it was all her idea well you know
it could have been that you knows one
month later married and suddenly they
are sending spy information to the
British and trying to make a deal so
they Andre even sends a secret letter to
Peggy saying hey I would be happy to buy
you sewing supplies I have a Z
to be employed by you you know and but
it's letters otherwise other than that
zeal the letters innocuous and Peggy's
and ultimately they there's a separate
level of level of communication with the
Benedict Arnold has with Andre and
they're not getting the money they want
what they want is a guarantee of what do
they want like ten thousand pounds if
they started at twenty thousand quid for
sale of Arnold and all his secrets right
and so so it takes more than a year for
them to get to this point but some of
the circumstantial evidence is that
whenever Arnold was away from
Philadelphia he would send these letters
to Peggy
that would be chock-full of military
information where armies were where
installations were weak where they were
strong
what plans for troop movements were not
the kind of thing that it's not pillow
talk it's not what a man would send to
his wife and who also coincidentally she
just happened to find a way to can those
messages to the go-between who took him
to New York so I mean is that
circumstantial evidence or is that her
as a spy so so ultimately they are about
to come to an agreement and John Andre
goes on for what it was almost yeah more
than a year really and so they have this
dramatic meeting at midnight and John
Andre and Benedict Arnold hold it al
Peggy is up in the house near West Point
where they were they've set up just a
real quickly they Washington wanted
Arnold to be a battlefield commander
even though he had a shattered leg
because he was so good and Arnold wanted
to be commander of West Point which was
his vital set of forts along the Hudson
River because he would be much much
easier to handover to the British
because it was a stationary you know
place rather than trying to surrender in
the middle of a battle might be
difficult people in the room who are my
age remember when
in the 60s when the news was full of
reports about efforts by the American
military to interdict the Ho Chi Minh
Trail because with us
what's the Napoleon the cliche army
travels on its stomach right no food no
ammunition no fighting army if you go
into a skyscraper in Manhattan high
floor and look across the Hudson River
to the west craning your head from left
to right you will see low ridges 30 or
40 miles out in New Jersey there the
Watchung mountains look to the right
it's the RAM opposed and southern New
York and then further to the right up
the river it's the Hudson Islands from
1776 until 1782 most of the revolution
in the Middle Atlantic states was a
stalemate
the British occupying Manhattan and
George Washington's army stretched from
Peekskill New York all the way down to
old down Middlebrook New Jersey and
neither side really well for various
reasons wanted to have it out with the
other side the supplies for all those
military people in those hills in New
Jersey crossed the Hudson River north of
West Point and West Point which is up on
a high bluff where the river makes a
very sharp - very sharp turns had a
chain built across it all for the
purpose of keeping the very powerful
British Navy from going up river beyond
West Point where it could interdict the
supply line so there's a reason why the
US Military Academy the sanctum
sanctorum of the regular US Army is at
West Point it was the strategic key to
victory in the American Revolution and
what you had was Arnold and Peggy
conniving to secure command of that
facility for general arm it's
interesting Peggy was doing her own work
to try to get him that appointment to
West Point
in fact Arnold's sister wrote a letter
to him saying that she was flirting with
very powerful New York politician Peggy
yeah she Peggy was and and which is
weird because in all of our study of it
Peggy never is inappropriately
flirtatious she's always very
appropriately flirtatious but she but
she was faithful to her husband and very
charming and proper but so this is one
aberration where Arnold's sister says
hey she's flirting with with Livingston
and Livingston was part of the process
of deciding who would get the West Point
appointment so I mean the theory is that
Peggy was working him to help get Arnold
the appointment and indeed he got the
appointment other great thing about that
if he's got a stationery appointment at
West Point he is up picking a house on
the other side of the river that's two
miles down and it's only 100 feet from
the river side so that you can make an
instant retreat instant escape and also
Peggy and their firstborn son Edward
who's been born by this time commitment
oh yeah who can move up there so they
set all that up and they have the
meeting at midnight between Arnold and
Andre just to make the last preparations
for how the how much he's going to get
paid and how much and how quickly the
British Navy is going to rush up the
Hudson grab West Point and possibly by
the way capture George Washington was
supposed to visit the Arnold's that very
weekend and so it all comes this amazing
culmination because even the evident
worked it might very well have set back
or ended the American Revolution but the
Washington is on his way from Hartford
where he's been meeting with the French
General Rochambeau who they were the two
people who ultimately won the war at
Yorktown later and he's coming back to
West Point to visit the works and
inspect the fort after the midnight
meeting skipping a lot of amusing
details Andre had to put on civilian
clothes and go back to his headquarters
in New York City by horseback so we have
Washington and his entourage headed from
Hartford to West Point
Andre going lickety-split by horseback
down to New York City to get the troops
mobilized get up the Hudson River and
invade West Point when Andre gets to the
bridge at Tarrytown across the Croton
River I think he stopped by three men
some people say they were thieves some
people say they were militiamen on guard
duty and they couldn't agree on a price
with Andre to release him so they took
off his boots some say to see if he was
carrying spy information some say to see
if he had money in his boots and they
found maps of West Point and documents
and Arnold's handwriting one of them
said we better turned this guy in so
they took him to a place in Westchester
where there colonel was the colonel was
mystified by this he didn't know what to
do he knew Washington was traveling to
Hartford so he sent the prisoner and a
note to Arnold with messengers and
guards and he sent a note to General
Washington saying he'd found something
you know suspicious so in effect there's
a race going on is how will the note get
to Washington before the note gets to
Arnold and Washington is now in Fishkill
at one town away from where the Arnold's
family house is and he's expected for
breakfast 11:00 a.m. and he says to his
entourage
let's stop I want to inspect this and it
was either Lafayette or Hamilton
according to Washington Irving who said
oh no no we have to go your excellency
we'll be late for breakfast with general
Arnold and Washington says oh I know you
young men are all in love with mrs.
Arnold and you can't wait to see her and
he offered them to go ahead but they
obeyed their commander and so with both
notes headed lickety-split for both men
guess where the first note got
if Sir gets to Robinson house where the
Arnold's are staying and so Benedict
Arnold reads the note and quickly goes
upstairs and tells Peggy and according
to witnesses you know it's a very quick
conversation and then suddenly he's out
the door
and he runs down to the waterside and
orders his barge to to go toward the
British lines down the Hudson you know
not toward a West Point but in fact it
was a little weird but he promised them
all a bunch of rum if they got there
fast and so they finally get to the
British boat which is called the vulture
and later Thomas Paine said it was one
vulture entering another and because he
gives up he says all right on I'm
joining the British side and so are
these people in the barge and they say
no we're not we're we're Americans we're
not going to join the British so they
just took a prisoner instead he said to
the British captain take my barge crew
as prisoners of war I mean what a creep
yeah yeah so all right so think about
this so this leaves Peggy in the house
by herself with her son she has been
told that the jig is up they do their
plot has failed and she's going to know
she's holding the bag and meanwhile
Washington is within minutes of getting
there
so what she ends up doing is she stays
upstairs stairs is very quiet Washington
shows up but the note to him has not
shown up yet so he's very seems very
weird he says it's really weird that
neither Peggy nor Benedict Arnold are
there to greet him he says I'll just go
over to West Point and inspect he goes
over and inspect and he's shocked by how
badly the fortifications have been
prepared because Benedict Arnold on
purpose was not doing a good job
supposedly
all right so meanwhile while Washington
is over West Point what happens to pain
she's upstairs and a note comes from the
colonel in Westchester saying for his
Excellency's eyes only so Alexander
Hamilton having had breakfast goes to
sleep in a chair and when Joran general
Washington comes back about four o'clock
in the afternoon mystified no 19-gun
salute for the commander no general
Arnold what's going on Hamilton wakes up
and says Oh a messenger brought this
note for you
Washington opens up and it all falls
together because he has figured out that
Arnold he'll what does he say Oh whom
can we trust now Arnold has betrayed us
in the meantime no taggi right so Peggy
Shippen upstairs as soon as she let
Washington get across the West Point in
effect to give her husband more time to
escape she launches on something that's
history with a little bit of history
that's been written about this has
called the mad scene and we call it - we
call it the mad scene because Peggy
Shippen goes completely crazy for an
entire day I mean like hysterically mad
she starts shrieking that there are hot
coals in her husband's head in there
they want to put hot coals in her head
she says her husband has flown through
the ceiling and he's been gone gone she
says that what General Washington is
trying to murder her child and she won't
let him and she shrieks down the hallway
runs around the house wearing very few
clothes also one of the staff officers
was Richard Varrick
Varick Street in Manhattan later the
mayor of New York and he says she came
downstairs wearing so few clothes that
not even a gentleman of the family
should have seen her so attired let
alone so many strange or contriving so
so all right obviously you know you
could you could genuinely see how a
woman who was completely innocent of
this plot and it just found out that her
whole life had fallen apart would be
upset so it didn't straight it struck
them it shocked them but I think they've
managed to process it in the way she
wanted them to process it which is that
she was just astronomers but also the
fact that this incredibly beautiful
woman is running around half clothed
couldn't have probably made the
who were more most likely to suspect or
not suspect her because they were
thinking about other things Alexander
Hamilton fell for it hook line and
sinker oh and if you really want to
appreciate Alexander Hamilton read his
letter to his fiancee that he's writing
his fiancee about how cool this woman is
and how and how he just wished he could
be a brother to her and you really
wonder well what kind of brother but uh
so I mean if after Hamilton needed
relief Lafayette took over leading one
of Lafayette s-- biographers to suggest
from his letters that Lafayette may have
had a sexual interest in mrs. Arnold and
then George Washington show something
and Washington being a family friend in
Washington I got to tell you two years
of reading about the American Revolution
to me only makes you like Washington
more and Washington you know is pretty
sympathetic shows up at her bedside says
you know what's wrong this is Shivan and
mrs. Arnold and she has she'll have
nothing to do that she says that's not
to George Washington that's an imposter
that's the imposter who's going to
murder my child and so she can't
recognize this man who's a family friend
and supposedly I'm she just you know she
just goes just stark raving mad for the
entire day and really alarming people
and you want to talk about what you
found in the story we had we had the day
with the man scene where she wraps all
the founding fathers around her little
finger and then one of my jobs in our
research was to go through this colonel
verax papers that are all at the New
York Historical Society and I'm in there
one Saturday going through my papers the
next morning after the man seen in her
hand which is very strong and easy to
read is a letter from Peggy to colonel
Varrick saying dear Colonel Varrick if
you are the army have any funds owed to
my husband please remit them to me
immediately which we had a quick
recovery from being in city fighting
from then on she has none of the madness
although you know it seems to be
courting sympathy when possible and so
she goes back to she's given the choice
of going to New York to join her husband
or going to Philadelphia to join her
family she picks Philadelphia but Joseph
Joseph reads people have ransacked
dollar papers and they found that
millinery letter that letter from John
Andre that said hey I'll buy you sewing
supplies now didn't say anything more
than that but some of them suspected
that that had opened up the whole avenue
of communication it didn't in fact but
it was the one thing they found that
kind of pointed toward Peggy and so they
banished her from Philadelphia before
she gets to Philadelphia she has to go
by carriage across northern New Jersey
and it's more than a one day trip so she
stopped to stay overnight at the home of
a lady she knew in Paramus New Jersey
which once did not have shopping centers
and the lady woman named feodosia Provo
was the fiance of Aaron Burr and Peggy
knew her and many years later after Burr
had died he his memoirs were published
and he says in his memoirs that she got
to Theodosius house when inside and said
Theodosia get rid of the staff I have to
talk to you privately and burr quotes
are saying oh I'm so sick and tired of
putting on airs about how terrible this
is it all fell apart on us at the last
moment and it was all my idea to begin
with
now when that was published in the 1840s
the shippin family had a fit about it
and accused Aaron Burr of having tried
to seduce Peggy and he fabricated this
to get even for being spurned right and
burr didn't have the greatest reputation
then too so it didn't really hold water
but it's the ship and family story seems
to not make sense so and by the time
Peggy gets to Philadelphia or a couple
of days later the Army has taken care of
major Andre he has been tried at
court-martial for spine
being a officer in the enemy army behind
our lines in civilian clothes the
lawyers in the room would be tickled to
death by his defense which he didn't
have any lawyers he never had any legal
training and his defense was that he
came in uniform under a flag of truce
and only donned civilian clothes under
orders of a senior officer of the
Patriot Army pretty doggone good
thinking on your feet when you're ready
to feel that noose around your neck only
it didn't work the 13 generals convicted
him and in a very dramatic scene after
asking to be shot rather than hanged and
having Alexander Hamilton become his
best friend he is hanged in a very
dramatic event with men and tears on men
his valet had been sent to give him a
fancy new uniform so yes Andrei is dead
Peggy is in Philadelphia and al Reed has
banished her and she she promises she
won't communicate with her husband but
they banished her then make her go and
so she goes to New York City her father
takes her on a very sad trip to New York
City to to rejoin her husband and that's
another unknowable and PEGI story of
whether she really wanted to rejoin her
husband or not the women were not
allowed legally to divorce at that time
the divorce law was passed after that in
Pennsylvania so women had almost no
choice she you know she couldn't stay
with a family she loved she just where
could she go other than rejoin her
husband she's 20 years old when all this
happens right and she only saw her
parents and her siblings one time after
she was banished from she was banished
until the war was over and then she came
back one other time but was treated very
rudely and people didn't like her very
much and so she only came once she had
spent her life in exile and in London
and in Canada and I mean the book goes
from you know birth to death and her
later years were very sad because
Benedict Arnold despite making more
money off
of the American Revolution that any
other single person was kept on losing
money and going and giving debt and
really his wife had a very tough life
and she was popular though in england
and queen charlotte liked her and the
through the recommendation of the army
she was given a pension for life of five
hundred pounds a year which was a whole
lot of money at that time right and
separate from from Arnold's he couldn't
touch it he went back in the shipping
business was constantly in trouble could
not call on American ports for obvious
reasons Peggy is back at home they end
up having six children together one of
whom was an infant who died in infancy
four boys and a girl survived he
developed a lot of business in Canada
mostly in st. John's and New Brunswick
had a girlfriend there had a love child
Peggy
found out about that and soldier Don
kept her family together as the four
boys matured they were given commissions
in the British Army and most they went
to India yeah and one of them ended up
living with an Indian woman and having a
child so Peggy has a half Indian
granddaughter and that who later moved
to Ireland and it's Arnold story oil
dies that just after he was sixty in
1801 leaving the family hugely in debt
by now
Peggy's father whose strategy for the
revolution worked he managed not to take
sides and end up a winner he is now in
1800 the Chief Justice of Pennsylvania
and we have extensive correspondence
between him and her in which her father
helps her work out paying all the debts
but the boys are all in the army and far
away and we found in one of her
descendants where we had a genealogist
help us a bunch of her letters written
in 1803 and 1804 to the same
child who was being cradled when the
plot broke up unfortunately she died in
1804 at age 44 of ovarian cancer and
when they went through her things what
did they find
they found a lock of hair to John Andre
had given her in Philadelphia now
there's always speculation of whether
that was a romantic relationship or it
was just a deep friendship and in fact I
I tend to think the time really liked
want to Peggy's friends there have been
her Peggy Chu the twos had more slaves
than the Chinese so I'd let that we'd
love to answer some questions if there
questions the audience microphone thank
you
someone with your gentleman's broad
interest that could get interested and
delve into anything how did you come
across this one and how did you just why
did you decide to delve into it among
subjects you started I 10 12 years ago I
read the Magnificent James Flexner for
volume biography of George Washington
and there are only two good stories in
there one of which I won't tell
it's about after the war and George
Washington wanted donkeys instead of
mules and there's a wonderful story
about how he went to the Marquis de
Lafayette to import donkeys you have to
read it the other thing that I thought
was a remarkable story was about this
teenage woman reminded me a little of
some of the very young women who got in
all kinds of trouble in the Vietnam War
protests Joanne Chesimard Susan
Rosenberg Patricia Hearst who've written
books about it and I didn't realize that
a teenage woman had gotten herself
embroiled by the passions of the
revolution and so I just kept my eye out
in my other reading and so over a period
of ten years which in a box that I sent
of Arc I accumulated 30 or 40 books and
kept looking for things and then I
proposed this to a literary agent
long story short who said hey it's a
great idea but you're a lawyer you wrote
too many loan agreements so the agent
introduced me to mark who is a skilled
able professional writer and between my
research and my comments and an awful
lot of hard work by Mark we got a
manuscript right and one of the things
that's really gotta be mentioned that
you know is part of Stephens research
tasks as well as going through all these
archives himself was to assemble a great
team of four archivists and researchers
andrea mayer stephanie Schmeling maurice
tango and new leonardo right and they
you know they went hour after hour day
after day they would go
and photograph original letters in the
Historical Society of Pennsylvania that
that archive has 41 linear feet of ship
and family papers and these brilliant
young people that helped us out went
through every single one of them and
they post six significant ones on this
server where I could get a hold of it
and Steven could look at it and point it
point me which way and they're also
great at because I had not heard of
Peggy Shippen until my agent Stephens
friend brought it to me and said you
would you like to work with Steven and
he didn't know what he was getting the
listener were yeah it's been a great
project and but they were really good
about not knowing much about it I had
all these kind of journalistic questions
and kind of newspaper questions in a way
where I would say hey I don't know
anything about the high hair worn by
women in that era can you get me a bunch
of stuff on that and they would ship me
all these academic articles about how
high hair was warned and that that
actually is pretty interesting some of
that stuff ends up boiling down to three
sentences a book of course but the
loyalist women were their hair really
high and that was considered a
difference between the Pro Patriot women
and the pro British women to where they
that the for the first anniversary of
July 4th in Penson Philadelphia they had
a mocking parade of somebody wearing a
hi hair and they had a parade through
Philadelphia making fun of the women
with hot hair
I mean it's a sidelight but at
Philadelphia after the British left
right after this fancy party was really
ugly in people were being hanged for
cooperating with the British and the
fighting between Arnold and Joe Reid
over who was the boss
going through this has changed my
attitude about the news reports about
Damascus and home and Aleppo and all of
the complicated mess there when
everything settles down and the
recriminations it wasn't pretty
philadelphia was an ugly place that year
one thing this book tries to do also is
put kind of a human face on the
Loyalists i think you know in school at
least I was taught that there were a
bunch of really great Patriots who
always did the right thing and then
everyone else was you know fiendish and
only wanted to crush freedom and Sons
guess what it's not that simple
um and I mean modern historians I've
seen one estimate that they feel like
40% of colonists wanted independence 20%
were loyalists and the other 40% just
wanted to you know not get killed in the
war and didn't really care which means a
minority were in favor of independence
it happened and I think for the better
they have a question I was just
wondering because he's the way you
described it all happened so fast with
Peggy marrying Benedict Arnold and then
shortly thereafter the the secret
correspondent the secret correspondence
with the British in New York City began
right
I wondered if did you find any any
reason to suspect that Andre had
actually suggested that Peggy get
involved with Arnold no I don't fact it
may have been we're not even sure I
don't think that it's that at least I
haven't ever read anything that
established whether they knew for sure
it's not clear whether the Arnold sent
their emissary to go find Andre or
simply to go to the British headquarters
in lower Manhattan but when they went to
the British headquarters in lower
Manhattan Andre was there so it's I
don't know that it's crystal clear that
they were asking for Andre but he was
totally the right person the right time
and it seems like quite a coincidence if
they weren't asking for Andre if you
read the 19th century literature it
pretty except for the bird
supporters it rather strongly militates
to the view that she was a sweet
innocent bystander exploited by her evil
husband in the 1920s the University of
Michigan Clements library bought
Governor General Clinton's
private papers and this then revealed to
the scholarly community for the first
time all of the secret encoded spy
communications which the common law
scholars in the room will be amused to
know the one of the codes they used the
most was based on Blackstone's
commentaries on the common law which
where was that going to come from except
from Peggy's father the prominent lawyer
and it was only when the secret
correspondence came out in the 1920s
that it was overwhelmingly clear that at
a minimum Peggy had not been duped about
the process and creates with the Bur
memoirs in my mind a strong
circumstantial case that she was clearly
a co-conspirator if not the instigator
now my lawyer friends in the room might
easily get past a motion to dismiss I
couldn't get I couldn't get summary
judgment but I think I could win the
jury case at least a civil yeah maybe
not criminal a preponderance of the
evidence standard I can't lose
yeah I have a question I in the book you
mentioned that that George Washington
upon reading the note and realizing what
Arnold has done that he he begins
weeping in front of I believe some of
his aides that maybe Alexander Hamilton
and I think it's mentioned in the book
that this was the only time off yet
right right Lafayette that he cried in a
sort of public setting or with people
around him and so I guess I'd love to
pick your brain on was his dramatic
emotional reaction more based on the
fact of a sense of personal betrayal or
was it maybe more a case of the
potential fallout and what it meant for
the revolution or maybe a combination I
think I think the war was so much in the
balance then that something like that to
such a tremendous blow like that was
yeah for just for the the survival of
the revolution I think he could have
been very upset but also yeah it was he
had kind of gone to bat for Arnold
Arnold made enemies everywhere he went
and people resented him and would always
spread rumors about him Washington had
no part of that when Washington
reprimanded him after the court-martial
it was very straightforward and it was
even after that he offered him the left
wing of his army so I think I think it
was just a crushing blow both of
personally and and and as far as the
fate of the nation as you know Lafayette
and Washington were so close
that during the French Revolution
Lafayette sent his children to Mount
Vernon for safety and what is remarkable
about the Lafayette letter that
describes Washington breaking down in
tears as Lafayette said in my long close
association with this man through the
early days of the war to the victory at
Yorktown it was the only time I ever saw
him break down and cry
other questions
if there
incident on right here yeah just a
little bit about Peggy Chu and Peggy
Shippen what what can you tell me I know
I know very little about Peggy to accept
that she's the daughter of the Supreme
Court Pennsylvania to house is the
battle of Germantown she eventually
marries Major John Howard Howard County
power County Maryland I think right
what's what's going on with those two
with that she's tied in this whole thing
well now if I'm right mark
there were we all know that a beautiful
young teenage women often have a group
of clothes other teenage female friends
and what was Peggy's group she had Peggy
shoe fit and she had two friends named
Becky one of which was Becky Frank's who
was a fascinating person with a great
sense of humor whose father imported the
Liberty Bell to Philadelphia and so she
it was a kind of a group of - Peggy's
and - Becky's who uh kind of hung out
together and Peggy Peggy shoe that's the
young woman who Andre took to the musci
on so that that was his state when he
was wooden they'll dressed his knights
or his Turkish maidens for that thing
and in fact in fact that one of the big
mysteries that we didn't speculate on
but talked about what the possibilities
can be was there's the family story is
that the ship ins did not allow their
daughters to attend the musci on set the
last minute a group of Quakers and a
family used to be Quaker so a bunch of
Quakers came to the door and said this
is terrible you can't you know consort
with the British this way and it's just
shocking plus those girls outfits are
just too you know too indecent and
argument about the outfits worked Peggy
Shippen and the evidence is mixed over
whether she went to the party or not
that did not stop major Andre from
drawing her picture wearing this fancy
Turkish maiden party dress we have
reproduced a cop
of that picture in the book it's one of
the objects in the Yale University art
collection it's one more to follow up on
really what your question really was
about Peggy Shue she maintained what
they called the birth birthday Club with
the British officers in New York so
there was a group of women by that time
Peggy Shippen was married so she wasn't
necessarily part of this but all the
British officers and all in New York and
they're friendly young ladies in
Philadelphia would toast each other's
birthdays and all their birthdays
separately kind of you know some people
look at the moon to think of each other
in different places they would do that
so there was this still this tie and in
fact that was discussed as a possible
way to get messages during this whole
conspiracy that you can step on Drake
could write to Peggy shoe and possibly
with invisible ink between the lines and
those would be sent to Peggy Shippen
there's no indication that that actually
happened but it was discussed in the
papers that were released in the 1920s
which is just another indication that
Peggy Shippen was aware of it because
otherwise why would you develop a means
of communication in which it would have
to go to Peggy's friend and then to her
Peggy's father was very good at
spoliation of evidence when news of this
reached home suddenly every document
anywhere in the ship and family
involving Peggy disappeared and we never
had a chance for a court of law to
impose sanctions for destruction right
but it but pretty much however many
people who think this and we certainly
think that there was a big after the
millinery letter was found and it was
proved that Peggy had been communicating
with Andre during the war through you
know through enemy lines all of Peggy's
friends and family we think burned every
letter that she had ever written and the
reason we think it is because none of
them exist and also because she was such
a prolific letter writer and all their
friends were prolific letter writers
their letters from her later years exist
and were a great source of information
for the book
these are remarkably articulate people
you read Hamilton's letters Peggy's
letters the complete transcript of the
Arnold court-martial was published at
his expense and you read that and you
say this guy real and Peggy two and a
Hamilton they'd all get the almost the
highest possible scores on the English
essay right I mean these are articulate
people with unbelievably broad
vocabularies right so the fact that that
no letters exist for most you know until
she met Benedict Arnold and then only a
few from that period all the good stuff
that you want to define nobody has ever
found there is back when they were
rating her papers there was a report
that she had written something really
catty about the French at this party and
it made fun of the French women who had
attended the party and that didn't help
her out much either
when she contacts Philadelphia because
the French were in high regard then I
just had to question the relationship
between Peggy and Arnold was that almost
something more of an arranged kind of
thing or was it true true love or I
guess what was the some of the
background seen then actually mail and
he wrote a letter to Peggy saying I am
you know it's unclear when they met but
it was soon after he came to
Philadelphia and he wrote a letter to
Peggy saying hey I want to court you
with the intention of marrying you and
wrote a letter to her father saying that
he wanted you know that I here are what
my intentions are and there was a long
period in which the family thought no
they especially thought they didn't want
you know such a young beautiful girl to
marry you know thirty eight-year-old
with a bad leg widower with three
children right right who would whose
money would some would go to these
children that weren't part of that map
of the new marriage so there were a lot
of reasons they didn't like the idea of
her marrying Arnold they Arnold at the
very last minute bought this beautiful
mansion in the Philadelphia area called
Mount Pleasant which kind of served
as an earnest gift I mean he kind of
bought it and says you know here's where
we could live and it was kind of I think
that sent a message to the family
there's no indication from anything
we've read that they weren't in love
with each other
he Arnold did stray and Peggy in one
letter talks about kind of the pain that
broader but there's she seems very
faithful to a man who was not very
likable so I think that but it was the
book gets into us a little bit
especially back then marriage was not a
decision made by two people marriage was
a decision made by two families you know
and there so there was great negotiation
and great deliberation before they they
said yes okay
one more question okay thank you
it strikes me that the overall plot as
you described it and it's it's a plot
that I wasn't at all familiar the
details until I heard your description
it seems like the the success was likely
a success was pretty tenuous I don't
know it seems that Arnold I mean that I
have that Condry Andrzej that the
likelihood that he would not not make it
through and that this that the whole
plan or for that matter that that the
strength of the forces at West Point or
whatever that seems like a big risk to
me the way you described
well it's something that a final
decision on the last minutes of the plan
was that upriver to have her straw for
the midnight meeting on the ship the
vulture and he was supposed to go back
on the vulture which would have been a
lot much easier than going back on
horseback a militia officer without
orders that Arnold knew about saw the
British ship and apparently on his own
initiative went out and fired out they
wheels up from the cannon and fired it
at the vulture to both the vulture and
forced it to withdraw and war Andre
couldn't get back on the show so he had
to go by land which greatly complicated
but he almost made it he was within just
a few miles of being of being back there
and they and this was the meeting which
they sealed the deal within days
a giant British fleet would have been
going up the Hudson trying to see his
West Point would they have succeeded I
don't know I mean they had a four-hour
meeting in the middle of the night and
Arnold presumably told them the best way
to get in and he weakened the place and
Andre had all the maps with the places
to send the army I think it was a close
call whether they'd have gotten there in
time to capture Washington and he later
wrote a letter saying he didn't think
the plotters were after him I think they
would like to have gotten there in time
to capture Washington but I believe that
because of the way Arnold had weakened
the defenses of West Point that if the
British Invasion
of the fort had occurred it would have
been successful you think that Arnold
felt that if they attack the planned
attack had failed that he would still be
safe that he would be undiscovered at
this point er my guess I don't think I
get it is that once the attack started
he and Peggy would have gotten them and
the baby would have gotten in the barge
and headed for Manhattan - for safety
whether or not the attack succeeded he I
mean part of the deal then the big
sticking point and the whole deal over
this more than a year period of
negotiations was how much he was going
to get paid if it failed he data all
agreed it was going to be 200 - I mean
20,000 pounds if it succeeded but they
were dickering over whether he'd get a
guaranteed 10,000 pounds that have
failed which the British didn't like but
he wanted so what he ended up getting
six if I ended up getting six which was
a lot back then thank you thanks very
much for more information about the book
and it's off